Міноборони Росії заявило про зрив, за їхніми словами, "великомасштабного наступу" ЗСУ
на 5 ділянках фронту на південно-донецькому напрямку.
І нібито навіть сам начальник генштабу Герасимов у цей період перебував на одному із передових пунктів управління.
Всього було задіяно 6 механізованих та 2 танкових батальйони противника.
Метою противника був прорив нашої оборони на найбільш вразливій, на його думку, ділянці фронту.
Своїх завдань противник не досягнув, успіху не мав.
У результаті вмілих та грамотних дій Східного угруповання військ втрати ЗСУ склали понад 250 осіб особового складу,
16 танків, 3 бойові машини піхоти, 21 бойову броньовану машину.
Тим часом управління стратегічних комунікацій ЗСУ попередило, що російські окупаційні війська
готують дезінформацію про контрнаступ і активізують свої інформаційно-психологічні операції.
Для цього Росія має заготовлені відео та фото, які показують підбиту техніку, загиблих і полонених,
а також інші фейкові матеріали про напрямки контрнаступу і втрати українського війська.
Українські військові експерти вважають: це через те, що у російських військових починають здавати нерви
від постійного очікування контрнаступу ЗСУ.
Це робиться для того, щоби просто створювати ілюзію, що міністерство оборони і збройні сили РФ контролюють ситуацію,
що вони не допустять того наступу. Тому що у них є цілий пласт роботи з дискредитації українського контрнаступу.
Вигадують операції, яких ніколи не було, і приписують собі героїчні вчинки.
У принципі, Конашенков будує на цьому свою кар'єру - віртульна реальність паралельна,
коли вони малюють знищення 10 "Патріотів", 15 "Хаймарсів" щодня.
Водночас Генеральний штаб Збройних сил України заявив, що не володіє інформацією про "масштабний наступ",
який, за твердженням Росії, розпочала Україна.
А міноборони України випустило відеоролик, в якому українські військові закликають до тиші,
заявивши, що оголошення про початок контрнаступу не буде.
Щодо цієї передбачуваної великої атаки, яка не була підтверджена, - це не велика масштабна атака.
Здається, була задіяна бойова група. В Україні є десятки і десятки таких бойових груп.
Протягом наступних кількох тижнів і місяців ми почуємо багато таких претензій
і дуже мало, я думаю, зустрічних тверджень з боку України.
Позиція українців поки що така: ми нічого не говоримо, поки чогось не досягнемо.
І взагалі, коли вони кажуть, що чогось досягли, вони справді цього досягли.
Очевидно, що протягом останнього року ми чули багато повідомлень від міноборони РФ, які виявилися не зовсім правдивими.
Тож, можливо, є ймовірність, що справді була спроба прориву російської лінії оборони.
Однак, що стосується масштабів цієї атаки та того факту, що російські війська відбили таку кількість українських сил,
включаючи дві танкові бригади, це виглядає, м'яко кажучи, непропорційним.
Ми не можемо точно знати, тому що українська сторона нічого не говорить зі зрозумілих причин,
тому що вони не хочуть розкривати плани. Однак ми повинні сприймати це з певною часткою скепсису,
принаймні до тих пір, поки ми не отримаємо якусь перевірку відзнятих матеріалів і дані від української сторони.
На тлі цієї війни дезінформації та дезорієнтації рішучі контрнаступальні дії ЗСУ можливі, вважають опитані DW військові експерти.
Про готовність України заявляв президент країни Володимир Зеленський.
Аналітики зазначають, що це не буде так, як намагаються подати міноборони РФ та російська пропаганда.
Це не буде одним ударом, це не буде одним масованим наступом, одним потужним штурмом,
як у Першу світову війну, бо ризик провалу великий.
Більш імовірно, що це буде серія операцій по всьому фронту для виявлення слабких місць Росії.
І це триватиме багато часу. Тому нам не слід очікувати швидкого розвитку подій.
Це тривала серія операцій, які, ймовірно, лише розпочинаються.
За даними військових експертів, українські війська зараз майже по всій лінії фронту "промацують" оборону росіян:
йде розвідка боєм, відволікаючі удари, маневри. Тому заяви міноборони РФ про зрив великомасштабного наступу ЗСУ передчасні.
У цих умовах, звісно, треба максимально заплутати супротивника.
Що наразі відбувається? Наприклад, на Бахмутському напрямку ведуться досить активні дії,
які, в тому числі, виражаються в тому, що українська армія поступово просувається флангами,
відсікаючи російські війська від Бахмута і створюючи умови для пастки в самому місті,
куди вже зайшла регулярна армія.
Збройні сили України провели локальні наземні атаки та, можливо,
досягли обмежених тактичних успіхів на заході Донецької та сході Запорізької областей.
Про це йдеться у щоденному огляді Інституту вивчення війни (ISW), опублікованому в понеділок, 5 червня.
Як пишуть американські аналітики, геолокаційні кадри від 4 червня свідчать,
що українські війська здійснили обмежене просування на північний схід від Рівнополя на Донеччині.
Це нам говорить про те, що українці намагаються вдарити по різних фронтах.
Тож повідомлялося про атаки в Запоріжжі, атаки на півдні Донецька.
Отже, українці намагаються проводити стратегію тисячі скорочень, як сказав Михайло Подоляк,
маючи на увазі, що вони шукають слабкі рубежі російської оборони і намагаються побачити,
де вони можуть прорватися, щоб надіслати підкріплення.
Під час літнього контрнаступу, за оцінками військових експертів,
Україна робитиме акцент на високоточних артилерійських ударах, далекобійних ракетах,
розвідданих від союзників і західної бронетехніки.
Винищувачі F-16, про які так багато говорять останнім часом,
за словами міністра оборони України Олексія Резнікова, влітку задіяні не будуть.
Утім, українські військові погоджуються з інформаційною тишею щодо контрнаступу.
Адже говорити про нього - не одне і те ж, що брати в ньому участь.
Процес контрнаступу займає дуже багато дій, дуже багато втрат, дуже багато праці.
Сказати про це по телевізору чи десь одному експерту сказати, що проводиться контрнаступ, там успішно, там неуспішно,
там нас піджимають, там ми піджимаємо -  це все дуже цікаво.
Прийдіть в окопи, сходіть на один штурм, сходіть на інший штурм, втримайте оборону,
посидіть під артилерією, не попийте води декілька діб, поїжте тушонки у бліндажі -
тоді ви зрозумієте, як воно проводиться. Поки ти сам цього не спробуєш, ти не зрозумієш.